salut bienvenue dans cette vidéo de type
exceptionnel plus grosse vidéo de la
chaîne nous allons faire un cluedo géant
dans un château avec quatre joueurs
d'exception amics m qui accroche ltr et
docks seven on reprend le concept du
clae dos en grand forme d'un petit peu
et on fait ça dans la vraie vie vous
vous doutez bien que pour faire une
vidéo de cette ampleur il me fallait un
partenaire et j'ai trouvé ce partenaire
en la personne de one plus mais le
nouveau one puis c'est quoi le nouveau
one plus c'est ça et quand je dis ça je
parle d'un écran qui prend tout le
téléphone c'est en fait c'est clairement
un gros tournant dans l'histoire de la
marque et le gros point fort c'est
l'écran où y'a rien n'y a rien du tout
il n'y a pas un poinçon n'y a rien du
tout s'apprend l'entièreté du téléphone
oh là là je veux faire à celle fille
qu'est-ce qui se passe il ya de cette
fille qui saria la caméra qui sort là
avec une sécurité c'est à dire que si je
fais juste ça bon ça reste ici mais si
sa chute de mes mains il rentre tout
seul à l'intérieur on est sur une belle
technologie
d'ailleurs ils ont énormément amélioré
les capacités de la photo on peut aussi
faire des supers photo grand angle pour
l'écran ils ont la meilleure note du
display mackinnon tous les écrans de
téléphone une qualité de visionnage au
top et surtout une expérience ultra
immersive
c'est un téléphone ultra performant qui
rivalise avec les plus gros qui a
actuellement sur le marché
la batterie elle est toujours nickel et
sa recharge encore plus vite qu'avant
maintenant on peut faire 50 % de
recharge en seulement 20 minutes je vais
pas vous faire toutes les spécificités
techniques du produit mais ça concentré
de technologie avec un taux de
rafraîchissement par exemple de 90 hertz
qui donne une fluidité incroyable
le système était ouf le 7 pro est encore
au dessus
c'est une dinguerie vous allez voir
durant tout le dos puisque nous on va
communiquer avec les joueurs par
l'intermédiaire de noah n'y plus
respectifs ils vont m'envoyer des photos
vous allez voir l'écran vous allez voir
tout ça et moi je vous en reparle un
petit peu à la fin de la vidéo mais vous
avez un lien vers tout ça dans la
description
voilà comment on va se passer ce cluedo
je serai dans un quartier général au
deuxième étage de la plus autour du pot
au château du clos au donjon et je vais
envoyer des sms à tout le monde pour
qu'ils puissent naviguer à l'intérieur
du château les pièces sont des vraies
pièces les joueurs peuvent aller où ils
veulent quand ils veulent et dans chaque
pièce se cache une énigme s'il arrive à
la résoudre
ils peuvent m'envoyer l'hypothèse joe
hart et intel avec tes larmes dans telle
pièce et si j'ai les cartes je leur
envoie virtuellement
par le sms du mois de plus et s'il n'y a
pas la carte ça veut dire puissant sur
une bonne piste pour trouver quelle est
la bonne combinaison sur qui a détruit
la chaîne de ces villages ah oui parce
qu'on vous a pas dit c'est céline h la
propriétaire du château
alors qui a détruit sa chaîne avec
quelles armes et dans quelle pièce du
château le crime a été commis comme dans
le cloud au traditionnel il y a 6 arme
potentielle l'article 13 le strike
larnack aux abonnés l'achat de vue le
dislike et le drama il y a six suspects
potentiels la société bidon l'abonné
choqué des suies leiter le roi des
fleurs et les ayants droit et enfin des
neuf pièces qui sont neuf pièces réel du
château que je ne vais pas vous citer
une par une
parce que c'est beaucoup trop long au
bout d'un moment dans les commentaires
vous pouvez d'ores et déjà m qui est
votre favori ou qui vous sentez qui va
gagner ce cluedo l'a donc pierre cros
amics m et militaire d'och seven tout le
quine de ce que le dos sur la gagner sur
mon instagram vous est le lien dans la
description n'hésitez pas toutes les
cartes le plan du jeu pour refaire ce
cluedo enfin seul credo c'est pas
vraiment un cadeau c'est le cluedo lit
car l'art mesdames et messieurs
bienvenue dans le cluedo l'icann
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hamza messieurs si vous avez ici c'est
parce que vous étiez disponible pour
résoudre une enquête particulière nous
allons faire inclus de grandeur nature
dans ce château à quatre niveaux
parce qu'un crime a été commis envers la
personne de mademoiselle céline h
d'entrée la victime on voit on voit une
forme de crise qui s'est passé dit nous
chercher à me saboter pas quelqu'un vous
a détruit votre chaîne youtube c'est ce
qu'on ait marqué dans le script
septembre en tout cas d'être une chaîne
youtube je venais à peine de franchir
les 100 mille abonnés et s'étendra et je
compte sur vous mes amis pour découvrir
une chaîne fait le même bruit que le
pire c'est qu'elle est vraiment en train
de pleurer en matière vous avez un
numéro sos il ya deux personnes qui
naviguent qui sont hors jeu c'est ce
sont fanny et pierre qui m'ont aidé à
faire le concept de la vidéo à tout
moment s'il ya une règle n'est pas clair
s'il ya une énigme qui est pas car
quelque part ils vous aideront s'appelle
game masters finale des masters et ya
aussi évidemment le fantôme de ces
ménages qui rôdent ici qui peut vous et
j'espère qu'elle en mode comme ça je
sais pas s'ils arrêtent pas comme ça à
personne
elle a parfois des choses à vous dire
des fois c'est pertinent et peut-être
des fois pas l'option non pertinents
votre grille de détectives vous pouvez
cocher des cartes que vous avez en main
ou que vous trouvez s'il est utilisé par
les vrais de vrai détective elle est
certifiée par son cher s'il allait voir
si ta femme te trompes au truc comme ça
ils ont vraiment c'est gris le tapis
tous les suspects alors après celle à
terme c'est une double est supérieur à
12 je file au qg
vous attendez cinq minutes avant de
rentrer dans une salle que je sois prêt
parce que vous allez me harceler de sms
en même temps je déclare
inclus d'eau robert nature avait
[Applaudissements]
directement commencé par là on va pas
perdre de temps je les vois les p'tits
loulous là en train de déjà perdre du
temps on prend la petite faute au tac
salon de la marquise pas part
directement sur un envoi
ok le premier joueur qui m'a envoyé un
sms c'est à mx m
il vient d'arriver au salon de la
marquise comme on le voit ici vous allez
pouvoir suivre ça c'est juste incroyable
le salon de la marquise dans ce salon
j'ai caché quelque chose de spécial ça
s'appelle un tangram en tornade il ya
plus de pièces là c'est un petit de 4
pièces qui est caché sous une cloche qui
est posé sur la grande table avec ça il
doit former une figure très simple c'est
la lettre t ça paraît simple avec quatre
pièces mais vous allez voir c'est pas si
facile
c'est quoi un tel drame c'est le truc de
et pic et pic et colégram tangram trouve
la boîte et envoie moi la photo pour
continuer un thème g jamais vu de
tangram de ma vie
[Musique]
cherchant tangram super les potes
tangram une boîte en bois pendant que je
cherche là que j'ai un petit peu rien à
raconter je peux peut-être d'avoir
balancé une anecdote aux gens fabien m'a
confié qu'il a loué ce lieu pour le
tournage et qu'il ya quelques semaines
c'est shakira qui avait loué ce lieu
donc être que shakira s'est assis là
voilà ici ça bon ça me fait plusieurs
parce que j'aime beaucoup de shakira
notamment pour sa musique avant tout et
militaires salon du bar on craque salon
du baron c'est très simple pas d'énigme
trois cartes de cacher dans le salon il
faut fouiller il faut les trouver et va
passer des heures
j'envoie le salon du bateau parce que je
n'ai pas le salut par hayate cartes non
[ __ ] c'est ça non ce qui est un peu
chiant c'est qu'à chaque fois je me
retrouve avec pierre on est tout le
temps ensemble genre de truc et on est
les deux ceux qui comprennent jamais les
règles est pas bien il va essayer des
trucs parker mais non jamais le conseil
est pleine j'ai envoyé une photo de ce
salon c'est tout elle commence à
regarder mes réponses tellement réussie
je sais que c'est pas le hunter parce
que du coup il ya une carte était assez
sûr j'ai vu comme ça que moi j'ai gagné
non la première chose que je ne me
souvenais pas du champagne importe quoi
alors là on est vraiment dans le linge
de maison quoi est ce que tout le monde
ait la saison mois les stocks
avec ça je suis mûr ou quoi j'adore
faire ça en vrai show cro cop gwan
du coup on est d'accord que je peux les
cochers c'est les cartes qui sont pas
dans le coffre puis à cause du temps
d'envoyer qu'il est dans la grande salle
qui est la seule pièce qui ne sert pas
du tout aux jeux aux énigmes donc je
renvoie qui doit trouver qui n'a pas
compris les rires je te vois à trouver
qui n'a pas compris les règles cette là
dessus
trop compliqué son truc qui n'a pas
compris les règles ou est ce que ça
pourrait être
et avec de sécurité plan d'évacuation
j'ai pas compris je dois vraiment faire
ça non a ok y'a pas d'énigme dans cette
pièce et m'a dit ok dans une pièce alors
ok j'ai doc seven qui arrivait dans la
suite la suite qui est ici donc c'est
parti pour doc seven la suite on doit
rentrer et où on en veut on a vraiment
trouvé la meilleure salle de but la
suite mon gars c'est mission impossible
sierre qu'il ya des lasers qui va
falloir éviter pour pas faire sonner
l'alarmé et m'envoyer une photo de la
bombe qui au bout de ces lasers dans la
réalité on a tiré défilent dans le noir
avec une lampe à uv
il faut qu'ils sont fils pour m'envoyer
une photo de la bombe en plastique dans
ma tête ça marchait
au passé en vision nocturne
je la vois aller là bas on l'a repéré un
c ur quand tu rentres dans la pièce tu
vois pas du tout les fils heureusement
qu'il a peut-être lumière alors attends
on va s'approcher au maximum
jusqu'ici
on va prendre une pause de photographes
pour bien lui montrer qu'on a vu ce
qu'il veut qu'on voit on va zoomer au
hockey on va lui envoyer un maton faut
réfléchir à ce qu'on va lui proposer
j'ai totalement oublié le hunter le dise
lite on va déjà de les cuire ben voilà
on en compte ici mais sa réponse on
gagne du temps et oui au trail hard dis
moi que tu as les trois comme ça on
élimine plein de trucs ou pas vous dis
moi que tu en as aucune d'ailleurs comme
se rendraient direct trouvé non il m'a
envoyé trois salons des anges dislike
later ok on élimine trois trucs de votre
liste ça c'est pas un tanga tangram ou
alors c'est un caméraman de poker mais
je pense pas hop hop hop hop hop
regardez moi ce thème g ah c'est ça ok
ok
et hop la photo du tangram non ça se
trouve c'est pas ça je peux même dire
c'est pas ça je suis en train de
vraiment de doute et là je peux regarder
sur google ce que c'est un tangram c'est
pas du tout ça
[Musique]
fabien va me répondre c'est pas ça et je
le savais je veux dire ah ok donc c'est
un thème g
suprise pied dans ma soutane qu'est-ce
qui aa [ __ ] ça ne leur est là depuis
le début
ok donc ça c'est un tangram temps et ce
qu'il veut que je fasse quelque chose
avec ou juste quand on voit la photo de
la boîte sachiez je suis très mauvais à
ça c'est sûr et maxime tu réfléchis tu
as regardé toutes les vidéos de samedi
en liga
bon allez je m'active là attention je
passe en mode jeu passant votre complète
depuis qu'il en a minima il vat avec
être au même endroit c'est comme si tu
les as vu juste pour sa riche faune dans
la cheminée non un bon endroit pour
cacher une carte ça il ya des araignées
j'ai l'impression d'être aveugle alors
qu'en fait je suis sûr qu'elles sont
hyper au mieux sans plus
on peut les voir rapido ça c'est
incroyable impression que tu sais quand
tu es chez toi et que tu cherches des
clés et elles sont devant troupe if
études et tu dois pas et c'est hyper
élan c'est ça avec les quatre morceaux
de blues est tu dois créer la lettre t
ah ah mais c'est bien sa façon
moi j'ai envie ça y croit j'ai envie
déjà envie de tenter de fabien il est
très occupé
je ravale entendu vous peut être marcher
je ferai jamais le gars est mentaliste à
la base donc c'est mort il va bien voir
qu'un petit truc qui cloche
ok j'en suis à un mix m pas vraiment les
gars envoie d'egypte
c'est fou
mais [ __ ] j'ai cherché dans la truck
mais alors je suis minéraux parce que
j'ai été de danger soulevé le bois est
au [ __ ] aller devant web
[ __ ] alors que j'ai fugué le truc quoi
elle il veut pas l île est sûre il est
sourd qui veut pas elle sait - les ailes
de se faire un nom je suis rouillé avant
j'étais méga show dans l'escalier
je suis devenu obèse si c'est de la
fouille s'est forcément sur un truc
j'étais tellement sûr sur ce thème je
vous forcément qui a une base à sauter
on est d'accord non sur une nouvelle
piste
cécile lettres dans l'alphabet qui
étaient découverts récemment en amazonie
qui signifie qui fait en fait le son
[ __ ] dernière
je jetterai réception je te la cache
encore mieux que ça un peu de pitié un
moment on a passé 20 minutes ici j'ai il
faut que je lui dise que je quitte la
pièce c'est ça non mais c'est pas
possible il ya quatre morceaux il ya
quatre morceaux il ya quatre morceaux
alors attends on va suivre les plans non
mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que la
veuve noire à l'asse fait hacker sa
chaîne youtube mais aussi sa vichy donc
c'est un fantôme d'une manière vraiment
très étrange et temps cherche le plan de
tournée où la mort est chaussé
rez-de-chaussée au rez-de-jardin la
[ __ ] je la chante partout tu es encore
dans cette question
c'est pas juste un mec si je suis là si
leur stand
ouais on partage des indices exactement
passé alors c'est très simple peu près
rapt et avec ça un t rex un intellect
mais c'est extrêmement facile un mari
parfait ah oui c'est quoi cet indice
c'est encore un indice à vous c'est une
anecdote personnelle je vois pas le
rapport à que tu vas voir c'est chiant
tu vas très envie de partir donc un
message famille en disant et genre
humain at elle dit il ya quatre morceaux
il fait sa rentrée qui est quand même
une forme simple ça déjà 35 s'est pas
adapté sa battue pas un terminus comme
ça je pense que c'est plutôt un lit avec
l'accent peu avec le gspr quoi comme ça
attends moi je peux pas car tout il
fallait le dire oui au nom mais je me
casse c'est bon tant pis quoi encore une
lente au x ore je veux poursuivre et
avec votre thé je me casse mais löw
attend que tu as comme ça trop dure la
grande dans la piscine c'est seulement
il savait qu'au bout de ce jardin dans
la piscine se trouve le de l'eau le thé
il avait fait ça depuis tout à l'heure
en fait et il avait que ces quatre
pièces il faut trouver se trouve mais
c'est que joueur à dessus mais peut-être
donner un
on m'a dit que le dessin avec ce que
c'est pour le t6 sa feinte et là moi je
vois un t6 indiquent ces pinter pas du
tout ça
[Musique]
convient au oui eric en même temps avec
ses mains pas le trouver jonathan je
vais déjà écrire m'a vu que tu sûre de
moi
article 13 est la pièce je vais finir
par trouver
tu vas être réception non je met chez
morphée ok bon de toute façon j'attends
ses réponses et je vais me mettre ici
voilà au nom il a les trois cartes merde
quoi que
c'est une pièce voisine keystone on y va
oh non mais encore là en fait un peu
flipper prendre l'ascenseur un mail à
bonjour j'ai ouï dire que vous aviez
résolu les dits oui tout à fait et à vue
revient déjà mis des petits des petits
pièges pour les autres tâches
et oui comme ça s'il passe par dessus
mon épaule ils vont peut-être croire
vous êtes facétieux c'est fou quand les
courbes
peut-être oui mais c'est pas une qualité
d'être faux or on y est on est haut dans
10 langues
ok donc ça c'est doc il est passé au
d'un dylan qui se trouve ici
le dandy village il y a quatre menottes
que les joueurs doivent se mettre et
ensuite ils doivent craquer la menotte
si alain bihr à l'intérieur avec la clé
doit forcer ce labyrinthe pour pouvoir
se libérer mais c'est gagné
on a un coéquipier écouter bonjour qui
fait c'est ma pièce salah ben faiza ici
peut-être des informations pour moi
ouais bien sûr on peut tu as ton est
censé lui
ouais ouais une au mont à 10 et oui dans
mes cartes et j'ai eu deux pièces c'est
lesquels s'ajoutent badel paye ton
indices génial ben moi j'en ai eu une
quasi fin analyse la ceni meetic que
mieux et bien moi je suis presque sûr
que le salon des anges
tu pourrais décrocher c'est pas ça à
minto summer tu vas devoir te mettre une
note sur ta main dominante tour attitude
droitier pour commencer pas simplement
eu de menottes à ton poignet à prendre
une telle ouverture du groupe yes elles
sont toutes fermées ces coups là on
n'est pas en des partis sur une demi
heure c'est voilà comment on m'ouvre les
menottes sait jamais sur un malentendu
peut-être qu'il va nous laisser un
indice on en est c'est une autre ça se
trouve à l'est je pense que shakira a
dormi ou plus de l'icca j'entre ça fait
vraiment flipper la barque là hors
caméra jb hockey j'utilise qu'on mène ma
disposition et on a mis à ma disposition
owen plus sept pros alors bombe
donc là faut que je passe là en fait
c'est par là haut
ah bon ça pose et n'oubliez pas un grand
chapeau ah ah ah merde
chapeau la fraîcheur tout était ok
vraiment les idées de vidéos à la combe
bien
non je suis passé
oh oui c'est bon j'ai des bombes
gd bouger les bons et les mauvais démons
vite vite vite vite vite vite vite gêné
bon fabien raboul les 1,10 à sa écrit
taboulé les indices ram a mis d'accord
ça tirait vraiment dessus et si ça
tirait dessus les bombes explosaient à
l'homme est vraiment en fait
non mais en fait ma vie était en jeu
depuis le début au pas du tout c'est
totalement faux espoirs ça va je pense
je pensais être plus harcelés de
messages quand j'ai écrit ce truc donc
pour vous expliquer si vous voulez vous
faire une version chez vous j'ai tout
mis dans les notes du téléphone et après
je fais des copier coller de sms en
fonction de ce que je reçois comme ça
j'ai assez peu de vraie interaction
mais les moments où je suis dans le jeu
c'est qu'on peut tous écrivent en même
temps d'être là ouais c'est sa selle
dortoir petit moment on va attendre son
petit message aux as il ya un truc là je
n'ai pas vu qu on en parle peu mais ce
château là est vraiment bon t'es prête
on y envoie un nouveau celle qui à
chaque fois qu'ils ne répondent pas
je veux qu'à la fin du tournage ils me
disent émus je ne peux plus tu arrives
au dortoir tu vas devoir trouver des
objets et qu'un détecteur de trésors
dans le dortoir les joueurs vont trouver
un détecteur de trésors il va leur
permettre de retrouver des deux clés du
détecteur ou alors un diamant le diamant
c'est l'équivalent du vivent dehors si
le choc le diamant en premier et qui le
met sur le détecteur alors c'est terminé
pour eux c'est gagné ou alors ils font
des clés dans l'ordre à tout le monde tu
peux abandonner quitter la pièce
on n'abandonne pas gilles muller fonce
dans le mur s'il faut dans la pente est
bon à poubelles à présent dans la
poubelle ça fait vraiment je crois que
si [ __ ] tu as trouvé les deux côtés
manquant du détecteur et les emboîter
dessus donc c'est pas ça c'est un truc
en plus ou alors c'est pas du tout un
trésor et on est content
ce serait bizarre sur un trésor sais pas
si c'est ça regarde tu as seulement deux
minutes pour ça c'est choquant diamant
te fait gagner instantanément
c'est génial si vraiment c'était que on
a trouvé le truc le plus compliqué et on
a fini les toiles c'est incroyable ce
qui se passe j'ai une chance de cocu aux
eaux
on a réussi je sais pas comment on met
un temps en temps j'ai pas envie de ne
pas pouvoir l'anglais ensuite fait un
peu peur mais ça fait 3 heures que
j'essaye non mais ça marche plus dans
technique en plus maintenant ok tu sais
que je les fais du coup le labyrinthe
pas pour l'ouvrir non j'y étais on y est
je crois
guest yes yes
vas-y je lui rends moi j'aurais pu
renvoyer la même photo que ça le fait
pas c'est bon maintenant il faut
préparer ton va pas aider les autres il
faut préparer ce qu'on va lui proposer
donc doc
doc geanah d'essai pour toi à mon avis
tu peut cocher le salon des anges
tu arrivé dans le salon de réception
dans cette pièce se trouve une machine
les clés c'est ça dans la réception là
c'est différent il ya une espèce de
vieille machine steampunk dans laquelle
on peut mettre des clés il ya trois
séquences de clé à trouver il ya
quelques énigmes pour les trouver
s'il arrive à bloquer les trois
séquences ils ont gagné ils peuvent
mettre leur hypothèse c'est fou de
jamais comprendre les consignes de rien
donc la bonne
et après start pour commencer à part la
séquence est simple ce sont les clefs 6
2 5 1 km mais à toi trouvé en quel ordre
alors 6 savez quoi je vais les mettre
dans l'ordre que j'allais prendre 6 5 2
à 6 5 2
et voilà j'ai pas d'un 10
oui enfin bien et très bien ta vidéo met
un petit coup de fil de temps en temps
qui on s'appelle jamais même aux fêtes
de noël tu m'appelles pas on passe passe
est en sang on attend dans un petit en
attente c'est le niveau nord c'est le
livre d'or
salon des enr juste merci le salon des
anges c'est un truc de sportifs du
dimanche
en fait il ya cinq bases qui sont plus
ou moins cachés à l'intérieur du salon
il y à un bâton et se battant on va
l'activer il faut aller le déposer sur
les cinq bases dans un ordre particulier
à la fin ça va arrêter le bâton il ya un
chrono qui s'affichent les joueurs
doivent me l'envoyer sérieusement ya un
socle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
ah il faut le rose ok il ya un socle
rose ça bouge et que j'ai compris ça
alors c'est rouge du petit [ __ ]
ok le vert vers le vert le bleu de bleu
villa le bleu et le jaune
j'ai pas vu john encore hélas le orange
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok j'ai réussi en un coup ça c'est bien
ça ah oui un film un ton souvent amers
d'avoir raison il va falloir faire
[Musique]
moi
il reste cinq secondes
[Applaudissements]
1 3 seconde
moi je te conseille et à quel moment un
détective privé doit faire ça pour
retrouver un meurtrier
ça n'arrive jamais oh le con l'avais pas
vu il avait pas vu que j'avais fait le
mauvais temps j'ai fait ça pour rien il
m'a valider le truc
je vais fait pour faire ça rapidement si
tu prends tous les peuples et tu les
appelles sur le bas je peux courir dans
toute la pièce dont 11 secondes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y avait un ordre hier franck dubosc
est passé ou alors quelqu'un qui allait
voir son spectacle la deuxième séquence
qu'on porte le nombre de semaines dans
une année et les extrémités d'un dgs 1 1
est là et après j'ai rien compris des 52
52 semaines
voilà alors un dé à un dé à jouer un dé
à jouer 1 et 6 1 et 6 1 déjà joués 1 et
6 1 et 6 hockey ont par contre est ce
que ça veut dire que c'est dans cet
ordre la 52e 1 6
je suis sûr qu'à la fin de cette
deuxième suspect attend livre d'or merci
pour l'accueil la femme morte fait un
peu flipper les guest qui arrivant dans
ce château une grand-voile contexte les
oc joli pari si bien dans mon antre on
prend la photo par contre ce qui
m'inquiète là
c'est qu'il ya un script ex ou je ne
sais plus comment ça s'appelle ce truc
et ça je le déteste un peu si on n'a pas
le mot j'espère qu'on va leur le mans la
cuisine dans cette cuisine à cryptex
n'est pas que du tout cachés d'ailleurs
il est complètement visible pour
l'ouvrir il va falloir prendre des
photos un petit peu partout dans le parc
et dans le château et il ya une
combinaison de lettres à retirer de ces
photos pour ouvrir le cryptex un an
quel enfer annoncé la femme que je
voulais pas non est-ce qu'il ya besoin
d'aller au deuxième de l'une des deux
chambres du dernier étage web vient on
va au dernier étage morphée je répète
morphée qu'est ce qui va me demander de
faire mais des petites pièces massa ou
encore un casse tête à la con pour
souffler là dedans
peut-être que j'attende quand même son
sms parce que je comprends rien je me
refais nous avons laissé un coffre fort
ce coffre fort pour l'ouvrir il faut pas
faire une séquence il faut trouver un
chiffre en nombre entre un et dix huit
ya deux manières de le faire soit on
écoute qui se passe dans le coffre on
réagit en fonction des indications du
coffre soit on bourrine les 18 chiffres
pour voir ce qui se passe j'ai une
méthode préférée quand même s'est
occupée c'est juste pour prendre une
photo une photo de quoi te rien de
vraiment laisser agir
bah c'est à dire juste au bon dieu alors
en échange d'un indice peut-être que
j'ai trouvé à randy motards ont redoublé
ma fille
revient à tout à l'heure
désolé denis je t'attends pas oui mais
du coup là il va rentrer l'autre quoi
j'ai retrouvé ma feuille je vous propose
un indice contre une photo vous réclame
pas c'est quoi ton à 10 bat peut-être tu
peux ouvrir d'abord je prendrais faudra
attendre autant je prends mes notes
oui c'est quoi ton avis je vais l'année
d'abord alors moi je pense que tu
pourrais cocher les ayants droit sont
qu'elle prenne tout pourquoi bas parce
que moi peut-être il me l'a envoyé quand
qu'en bas quand je fais une des énigmes
laquelle dans quelle pièce je sais plus
elle rappelle toi et on s'en fout c'est
moi qui lui proposait blanc d'accord
d'accord d'accord ayant droit ok oui bon
bah finalement une photo merci bras mais
vraiment merci beaucoup allez salut
c'est très humiliant
allez au revoir bon parfum
[Musique]
ces bons petits secrets
j'ai deux pièces dedans allez hop là où
tu as réussi c'était envoie une photo du
coffre où berne a quelques hoquets tac
m'envoie pas trois cartes uim on envoie
une rattrape trop tard maxime rattrape
son retard
seoul la pancarte ici là je vais en
chine est là qu est ce que je suis et
que c'est moi et [ __ ] je connais et tu
vois ça c'est vraiment là aujourd'hui je
suis un peu coup parce que je n'ai pas
mis au bon endroit mais comme j'ai un
prénom
enfin c'est pas un problème de leur
dette comme ça merde moi je peux plus on
a trouvé comment sortir ça c'est bien
pour commencer pas simplement une
menotte à ton poignet refermera y avoir
une photo du poignet à tout moment tu
peux abandonner quitter la pièce mais
[ __ ] me prévenir en anglais parce que
ce que j'ai fait quoi ok bah c'est fait
j'ai eu honte personnes non mais t'as vu
j'ai réussi à me sortir c'est pas comme
s'ils étaient restés fermés
j'ai trop plus tant le hasard comme le
sait une chose ou est là du coup j'ai
pris de l'avant ce moment j'ai pris de
l'avancé un petit peu du coup il a
galéré 2002 à la suite logique de
l'avant dernier
c'est pas réviser les matelas j'en sais
rien le deuxième est la différence de 4
avec le premier les derniers la suite
logique de l'avant dernier la suite
logique de l'avant dernier deux siciles
différence de 4 ensuite il ya deux
identiques mais se touchent pas donc
j'imagine qu'ils aient encore 1 2 est la
suite logique de 2 c'est quoi la suite
logique 2 2 je suis sur la terrasse
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
il a dit d'entrée aulas bonjour bien
pour accéder plus vite à la sage et une
simple question oui où se trouve le
dernier étage
oui j'oubliais tu as très bien puis je
prendre une photo en fait non bien sûr
tout à fait parce qu'on a les seins que
morphée n'ont-ils photos des escaliers
au journal oublier les escaliers yes
comme ça c'est la pire là les menottes
maintenant elle était bien à côté en
plus qu'à attendre sa réponse
à dire que si on parle de 2 partons de
deux ans suite logique ça peut être
qu'on est trois
5 1 5 300 peut être logique même pas
[ __ ] mais oui j'ai tellement pas
envoyer ça attaque
en fait il est il est trop d'attentes
auxquelles on faire son truc
ok ensuite deuxième lettre
ok vous non dernière première troisième
dernière première phrase est donc des
bonnes attentions occupé à l'art dote de
cleval j'ai une question
[ __ ] je me suis perdu si je te donne
aux quais bas début des matchs que je te
coucher cunha pas c'était peut-être un
bon truc voisine mais y'a pas de souci
non mais je me permet de prendre photos
théâtre qu'elle a vraiment fait ce
qu'est vraiment le pire est rattrapé le
retard hier alors à temps
[Musique]
y a rien dedans
tu as vraiment pris une photo de mes
notes ça tu peux peut-être me donner du
coup un indice sur une salle un indice
sur une salle des bâches plan pando non
voyant ces images pour elle alors ouais
merde c'est con allez bonne journée
avait fallu gerbe raison que nous on
tombe sur les trucs les plus galère
direct en vrai en vrai là avec cette
pièce là on allait suspect l'objet du
film déjà ils n'ont que leurs yeux et
avec un peu de chance et la carte qui on
verra pas ce qu'il a décidé de pas nous
aider j'ai l'impression d'attendre un
titre qui arrivera jamais
j'ai mis mes plus belles robes je me dis
ouais ce soir je lui déclarer ma flamme
et où il vient pas ou une veuve qui
oublient c'est que les attendait birsa
et le béton km heure
ok c'est bon on va trouver alors
maintenant je vais lui donner
ayants-droit attendant on n'approche pas
ma branche surtout pas je veux pas
parler
bah ouais pas de souci il paraît que tu
es très bonne soucis a dit inquiète
[Musique]
alors
je te parle je te parle à cames pour
qu'on se parle tout bas
presque tous j'ai presque tout donc là
faut juste que je réfléchis je vais
donner le dortoir il va pas envoyer la
carte donc le dortoir c'est bon soit je
monte maintenant je prends le risque
mais j'ai une chance sur deux et vu que
j'ai l'air un peu d'avancé le roi des
first c'est sûr donc j'essaye de faire
une dernière énigme
il a dit à lui et à l'avenir mais là
petit peu utilisé je crois dans une
situation d'urgence le mec qui dieu a
par contré par le mur ses favorites et
trempé quoi on vient ressort un sms de
la part de fabien qui dit si vous avez
reçu les achats de vue c'est une grosse
erreur
donc c'est à dire qu'il n'est pas censé
nous enlever les achats du donc j'ai
gagné puisque j'ai trois solutions là
c'était exactement les objets du crime
qui me manquait vas-y mon manteau ou le
stress la clé ou si vous l'accusez
allez oui
cela consiste
alors qu'il est si le qg
on est toujours
attention je le chambre un peu fainéant
rien [ __ ]
c'est encore au tueur
[Rires]
quelqu'un a trouvé ses marques et stop
c'est qu'il ya trouvé voilà la belle
fait pas et dit stop
rendez vous dans la grande salle non
mécanique et ma vie là du coup j'ai pas
pu donner mon hypothèse je suis dégoûté
puis ça nous trahit comme ça là c'est
bien toi oui
[Musique]
mon moteur oui et le roi des forces
je suis d'accord on monte parce que tout
le monde là je le sais là c'est plus
forcément tu vas me le dit découle de
marseille et le moratoire de dortoir
ouais merde c'est pas important je les
envoyais et toi tu m'a pas envoyé dans
saint louis ainsi s'achève cette vidéo
wii pierre cros a gagné bravo albi aller
bravo à ceux qui avaient misé sur pierre
crozat les commentaires au début de la
vidéo
encore une fois un énorme merci à one
plus de nous avoir suivi dans cette
aventure cette vidéo ça fait depuis 2016
que l'embellie des c'est un zoom actif
énorme pour moi d'avoir pu la réaliser
vous avez le lien vers le one plus le
nouveau dans la description il ya six
endroits où je vous recommande également
d'aller tout d'abord l'instant g de
crise qui a fait tout le graphisme de ce
cluedo licard bravo à lui défoncer son
instagram c'est beaucoup trop cool
évidemment si vous n'êtes pas encore
abonné ou que vous ne connaissez pas la
chaîne dame xm de pierre cros des
militaires de daube seven et de ces
ménages qui a vécu cette perte
potentielle de sa chaîne et ça c'est pas
simple ici vous pouvez également vous
abonner à ma chaîne pourquoi pas ici
c'est la vidéo de la semaine dernière et
si notre vidéo tout aussi intéressante
est ici ma chaîne secondaire oui
monsieur secondaire
moi je vous dis à très bientôt ciao